what's up guys
i think that we don't know if it's
turning on or not but it's lunch money
time
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get her lunch
money right
that was weird but welcome i'm here with
the beautiful
and intelligent polina pompliano i have
no clue what she's wearing right now she
looks like she belongs in a zoo
no with this little lion what is this a
cheetah pepper
leopard a leopard powder you have
shoulder pads things like your foot
literally got shoulder pads is this
where this is that is
the nanny fran fine if you remember you
know what i'm talking about she's got a
big hair
back she had a big haircut i tried i
couldn't get that also
guys don't panic i've seen the comments
i do not own
all of these clothes i do not own the
shoulder pads this is rent the runway
this is why i am able to why why bring
the fun
every day why do they have solar panels
i don't know that's the weirdest thing
but i do look like a linebacker i feel
yeah like you're gonna run me over
like sack me i don't even know what on
linebacker is i just know it's like a
big dude
yeah it is it's on defense they tackle
people i tackle people
yeah no you don't you you get uh do you
know what a heisman is
whoo no like a stiff arm oh yeah like
that
yeah but why do you see it there's no
microphone
all right what's going on um oh yeah
hold on timeout before we talk about the
topics
lunch money is now sponsored by block
five block five's got three products you
can buy and sell crypto you can deposit
crypto and you can earn
up to eight point six percent apy an
interest-bearing account or you can
deposit crypto and you can take out a us
dollar loan against it no-brainer i'm an
investor in the business
i'm a user of the product bitcoin pop in
get money get paid
i don't know why she keeps doing this
weird uh
fake stiff arm but go to block five.com
lunch money all right let's go into the
stimulus package okay
so the republicans have formally
unveiled the one trillion dollar
senate gop stimulus proposal saying the
american people need more help
these people are all ridiculous so it's
a roughly 1 trillion
which includes a 400 cut in enhanced
unemployment better now
see this is where the news is fake cnn
writing fake news here's what ends up
happening
is that the democrats put forward a
three trillion dollar stimulus package
they had
all kinds of crazy things in there uh
basically anyone wanted a bailout gets a
bail out anyone wants you free money
gets free money
and just let's just throw it all to the
wind and we'll just print
three trillion dollars the republicans
known as the fiscally conservative folks
step in and they say hey we only want to
print one trillion dollars
which news flash isn't fiscally
conservative but they want to only print
one trillion dollars
that includes they're going to get rid
of the 600
federally enhanced unemployment
insurance that extra 600
a week get rid of it that got stopped
being paid this week
and instead what they are going to do is
they're going to move to a 70
replacement for your wages so if you
don't have a job now you're on
unemployment
they'll go back and look at what were
you getting paid beforehand and they'll
calculate that and you'll basically
receive
70 percent of your wages which is
equivalent
to up to a 500 a week
federally un uh enhanced unemployment
insurance
they also have about 190 billion dollars
that's going to be in the ppp program so
more money for small businesses
low-cost loans that are potentially
forgivable there is about 15 billion
dollars that is gonna go
towards uh covid testing there's 25
billion dollars that's getting handed
out
for uh vaccines and other therapeutics
there is uh if i remember correctly a
hundred billion dollars that's gonna go
for education
30 billion of that hundred is going to
end up going for colleges and
universities
uh to restart schools no i'm not i just
off my head because i read the internet
it's all up here my favorite part of
the entire package is there is a
completely
unrelated allocation of over a billion
dollars
to rebuild the fbi's building in
washington dc
why because donald trump owns a hotel in
washington dc
and supposedly there was a concern that
the old fbi building that is being taken
down
could potentially give room for a new
hotel and competition to come in
and so we got to make sure we rebuild
the fbi's building
this is the crazy part of all of this is
why
is all of this nonsense in the package
right
there's also things like you can now
write off business meals there's tax
credits there's all kinds of stuff in
these packages but
is anybody reading these packages front
to back of course
who like all of the interns
but great you're telling me that there's
literally people who are coming out
right now and they're saying
uh uh democrats they're saying this is a
bad starting position
we're not gonna agree to this and it's
like there's no way you read
the hundreds of pages of the package
right now they probably are able to
quickly pull out the key pieces
they have interns who kind of go through
it whatever um but but it's just you you
get in this weird world where like
the difference between printing 1
trillion and 3 trillion
doesn't really matter in the sense of
all of the
billions of dollars that are stuffed in
the various aspects and nooks and
crannies of the economy
everyone forgets like why do what are
they gonna do with 25
billion dollars for vaccine development
and how about
15 billion dollars for covet testing if
you gave that money to the private
sector they would be incredibly
efficient with it when you give it to
the government they basically just light
it on fire
i don't know but what i do know is if i
ran for political office in this
i would immediately get elected no you
wouldn't oh yes i would
no okay no you know what they would do
no jp morgan
virtual credit jpmorgan chase has
partnered with fintech startup marketa
to launch virtual credit cards so it
says instead of receiving a plastic
version of your credit card in the mail
jpmorgan chase command what are you
doing come on
keep going i'm trying not to distract
you jp morgan commercial card holders
will be able to spend immediately in
mobile wallets such as apple pay
or samsung pay can we already do that
but now we have to wait for the credit
card to get here
no remember when you signed up for the
apple card yeah
and goldman sachs is backing it but you
immediately could use the virtual card
basically now jp morgan's gonna offer
the same was that tight
well didn't you like that yeah but
i could have waited the two days for my
card to get there okay but you didn't
have to
and you thought it was cool and so now
jp morgan's partnered with marquette
marketa or however pronounce it uh and
they're gonna do the same thing and
they're gonna offer to their customers a
very similar experience
isn't this good news for something like
bitcoin why
because you're not touching any cards
any money anything
uh no this is credit so it's different
like it's not actually replacing money
shows you how much i know but but also i
think that
uh at the end of the day like all the
stuff's going virtual so virtual cards
right you can swipe your
your phone whatever um a lot of people
they forget like when you use credit
it's not money it's credit
right and so uh mo let's say starbucks
for example i don't know the exact
numbers
my guess is that most people are using
credit to buy at starbucks not actually
using the dollar
right because they're using they're
they're basically using the credit and
then they pay off the card later
no it wait do you mean on your starbucks
card
no i'm just saying like like just the
transactions in general at starbucks
because credit is so heavily used in the
united states
so of course having a virtual credit
card makes a lot of sense
but again we're so far behind asia and
other uh regions in the world with this
stuff
i know we can't even okay so he sees me
i go to dwayne reed i try to
you know do my apple pay with my phone
and then i have to take the mask off and
then put the mask on and then
it just it can't recognize me with the
mask on like apple fix your [ __ ]
well it's called facial recognition
technology and it uses 12
or more points on your face and you're
literally covering up some of the points
of your face well that's their
problem they they know we're wearing
masks make it stop
would you like to have the security on
your phone or would you like anyone with
a mask to be able to open your phone and
spend your money
they don't want my money all right
what's going on with the greatest
restaurant in america
i have sad news for you what revenue is
down 30 percent
oh interesting it's almost like i read
the internet today
despite the progress at its u.s
restaurants revenue is down 30 percent
and its u.s same source sales shrink
just 2.3 percent
in june yeah so basically the fact that
same store sales in the united states
shrank 2.3
in june means that most of the worst is
behind mcdonald's like it's probably
going to only get better from here
uh the fact that revenue only went down
30 percent some people look at that as
really bad i actually think that's a
pretty
good number like if you look at airlines
most of them went down 80 90 percent
um there was a shelter in place order so
we literally sent people home
non-essential businesses couldn't be
open like all these issues and they
still only lost 30 revenue that's not
bad
uh on top of that if i remember
correctly
i think that 80 of the revenue or some
very large number
uh was through drive-thru only so if you
do control f right now or command f
and type in drive uh in then you
probably
can uh four percent so outside the us
restaurant closures
hampered sales but ninety four percent
of locations had reopened to partial
operations by the end of the quarter
that doesn't tell us what we were
looking for um but in some places like
china and brazil same store sales had
fallen 32 percent in april 20
in may and 20 in june so the us is
actually one of their best performing
regions uh if not the best
um and really it's just because did we
go into a hard lockdown
uh versus other countries not really
like people could still go out people
could still go
um and do things and so the second
quarter net loss i think it was uh 480
million dollars or something like that
uh look the best performing or the best
restaurant in america
hanging in there no problem they're not
going anywhere they're gonna still keep
giving you exactly the food that you
expect
at every mcdonald's for a great price in
every city
why they're great mcdonald's i had my
like sixth birthday there
it was a great time okay all right
what's going on with the mars car all
right so nasa has built
a self-driving car for its next look at
this thing for its next
mars mission and why are they calling it
a car isn't it
don't they usually call it a rover i
think it's a car
uh you know i should have read this
article no
if you go right here and it says how uh
later this month nasa expect to launch
its latest mars rover
perseverance on a first of its kind
mission to the red planet its job is to
collect and store geological samples
yada yada whatever it's significantly
more autonomous than any of nasa's
previous four rovers it's designed to be
what philip twa
a robotic systems engineer at nasa's jet
propulsion laboratory calls
a self-driving car on mars but here's my
problem with this
one it's not a car two they act as if
every rover that they've ever
sent isn't unmanned but this is cool
because they're sending another
rover no but my point is that every time
they've sent something to mars
right there's nobody in the car right or
in the rover
it's unmanned i know so it's remote
controlled they're claiming
that this can make it uh like the
software is gonna actually make the
driving decisions for itself
we're moving closer and closer to being
able to continuously drive and think
so yes this is classic we want to seem
cool smart shiny sexy and we're
recruiting smart people to come work at
nasa
there's no autonomous car on mars i
would rather
the cool shiny smart people work at nasa
versus somewhere else but why wouldn't
they just go work in a private
space company that is actually able to
um
better allocate resources and get better
results because nasa needs some shiny
smart people too
yeah that's fine but i don't think that
it's fair to call it an autonomous
vehicle
instead what i think you can call it as
you can call it a mars rover
and a technology enabled and kind of all
kinds of things
could be cool if we sent our roomba up
to mars and it just like kind of
went around so it says uh somebody said
the more complicated the system is the
more types of decisions it could make
not shocking making sure you've covered
every possible scenario that the rover
might run into has been very challenging
but it's doing a lot of really hands-on
tests like this that we find quarks in
the algorithm
so they're trying to build autonomy into
the vehicle but remember we don't even
have autonomous vehicles
in the united states driving on the
highway yet so the fact that we're gonna
try to send one to mars
okay but like mars there's kind of le
fewer obstacles than crazy cars and
pedestrians no i i actually think that
the autonomy problem on mars is harder
than the problem here because we don't
know what well one
it you're literally preparing for a
place that humans have never been right
two is it's not like you're just driving
on a flat surface
three is you've got to actually uh worry
about
much much worse obstacles right remember
on a road there's lines on the road
and therefore it's very easy for the uh
car to understand
stay within the lines and you basically
do object recognition
and so on a highway the autonomy problem
isn't that hard like tesla's autopilot
pretty much has cracked it it's in these
scenarios where
it's complete open area that's very
difficult
okay that's fair i still think it's
easier all right jamie foxx what's up
jamie foxx okay apparently jamie is like
one of the few celebrities that doesn't
have a tesla has never driven one before
so in a 13-minute video he recently
posted to youtube
he borrows a friend's tesla model 3
performance model
for a test drive and in it
he says he says
he goes from zero to 60 and he says
holla at me elon
so i got a great jamie foxx story what
you got a lot of people don't know this
story but he went on the tim ferriss
podcast a while ago
wait i sent you that yes and uh many
people don't realize this but jamie foxx
uh was just an actor right and
one day he's like i want to get into
music so he built a studio at his place
and he would throw these big parties and
then he would get somebody
he would get somebody who's in the music
industry but here you go come back to
the studio real quick and they've been
drinking and stuff
he'd make yo just leave just leave me a
track and he would have them record
something and then they would go away
and uh one of the people that he brought
back there
was kanye west before kanye had really
blown up like no one knew
in the corner by himself and so he
brought kanye back there
uh they uh recorded kanye and then jamie
foxx recorded a song as well and
do you remember what the song was oh
is it the one in the strippers in the
club yeah i freak i forget the name of
the song
but like the very first song that kanye
that jamie foxx ever did
exploded and it was like a chart-topping
hit
and then uh yeah marvin gaye that isn't
that what it's called
gold digger it was gold gold digger yeah
so the gold digger song
and i think slow jams maybe two i think
it was slow jams and
uh gold digger uh were like two big hits
right out of the gate and then everyone
was like oh wait a second this jamie fox
guy is now a musician as well
so jimmy fox he's ahead of the curtain
he's ahead of the curve he talks about
throwing these parties and having his
grandmother who lived in his house there
and people are like hey jimmy there's an
elderly lady out in the front he's like
i know that's my grandmother yeah
leave her alone she gonna get lit later
uh all right speaking of lit what's up
with dj
diesel my god guys this is my favorite
story to come out of
quarantine in 2020 overall are we still
considered in quarantine
yes okay goldman sachs ceo david solomon
dj'd a concert in the hamptons
the winklevoss twins attended and now
the concert is under public health
review
after cuomo tweeted a video from
from the concert where it's a lot of
people packed together
and it says cuomo said videos from a
concert held in
southampton on saturday show egregious
social distancing violations i am
appalled the department of health will
conduct an investigation
we have no tolerance for the illegal and
reckless endangerment of public health
and can i take can i tell them my take
sure
my take is i am absolutely here for this
showdown between cuomo and david solomon
because the ceo of goldman sachs yes
because
because cuomo has been going after small
business owners and
going as far as arresting them
in new jersey oh shoot okay sorry never
mind
fake news cuomo has not arrested anybody
but he's been going after
small business owners who have done less
than we just
taken liquor licenses and all stuff here
here's a real hot take
what about the egregious and illegal
endangerment of public health at the
protest
what's the difference between a protest
in the street and a concert
everyone's packed in together i don't
think
that's real facts by the way i'm
pro-protest
right i'm also pro-concert so it's not
uh
you know hey i don't think that there
should be pro i actually think there
should be protests i understand why
people are pissed off
but also if you're gonna allow the
protest then you gotta allow the concert
yeah but the cancer goers were without
masks
there's plenty of people out in the
street in the protest that have no masks
as well
and so the point is this is classic
classic
political posturing andrew cuomo should
be arrested and put in jail
for one specific thing he got 10 000
plus
people killed in the state of new york
because he mandated the fact
that they took people who are elderly
and were with covid and sent them back
into
the uh elderly care facilities so
you're talking about a guy who made
decisions who very directly and
you can attribute his decision making to
getting people killed
is arguing about a concept back back to
this i
am very curious if cuomo goes after
the ceo of goldman sachs but that's not
what he's trying to do is it
or is he trying to the concert goers
like the concert organizers or he's
going after
the org of course the organizers who
cares about who went i know but he's
just like a dj there he didn't organize
the concert did he
well by the way the mayor of southampton
organized it
oh jesse warren was the emcee
what was it a uh fundraiser
i don't think so yeah interesting
um i mean look at the end of the day
again it just goes back to
you can't start to pick and choose
what's okay for crowds of people to uh
collect outside you can't say oh if you
are protesting i would argue
that protesting is your right going to a
concert is not your right
no the freedom of assembly is your right
in the united states right but does that
include concert
uh again what law are they breaking
yeah you're things that you can't you
can't answer my question
no yeah it is the the freedom of
assembly the concert is not in the
constitution
going to a concert it is your freedom of
assembly
to protest you but you can also do it
for other things as well all right
but we're moving on it's like going to
church the freedom of assembly
is protected as well anyway my point is
we can't have
our 50 person freaking reception for our
wedding but
this can happen and second of all do you
think dj diesel would come
dj our wedding no why huh
why because he's very talented he's into
bitcoin
oh my god did you see my joke no oh my
god i think you did
no i didn't okay um guys
this is the joke time no not yet you
have three seconds i have something else
to say
okay that was the title so
you know i write the profile and on
wednesday show them your shirt
oh yeah i got the shirt on right now
everyone should go subscribe to the
profile readtheprofile.com anyway
readtheprofile.com readtheprofile.com
so my point is um on wednesday i have or
tomorrow i have the profile dossier
coming out and it's on an individual
person
it's a deep dive and it's this week it's
on uh psychologist
paul ekman who came up with the micro
expression
of the face and he's like a deception uh
expert and so yesterday i
we what do we watch lie to me it's a
show
based on ekman's research what do you
like about it
he basically can just ask questions and
watch how you react to them and it can
tell if you're lying or not it's
absolutely nuts
and for people who have really
expressive faces it's very hard for me
to lie
without people noticing and then what
they do is then they show you people in
history so like bill clinton and others
where they like touch their face like
this like that's a
thing of shame or they make a certain
thing with their mouth or their face
and you can tell anger or lying or
whatever it is
and so they're going through it in kind
of scenarios in the show
and then they basically pull it back out
and they show you here's a bunch of
examples of people having done this in
the past
uh that could have told you very early
on that uh they were lying
it's cool right it's very cool all right
what's your joke let's go for my joke
what do you call a fake noodle
a fake noodle yeah
i don't know impasta
that was that one was all right that was
all right we're i'm gonna start rating
your jokes that was like a
that was like a b minus that was like a
nine no well
you you can't use numbers in a letter
scale eight b
b minus it would be a b so
uh i don't know what school you went to
what out but in the schools i went to
300. if you got a 80 that was a c
we were very tough graders where i came
from oh my gosh so what did you get on
your exams i got a lot of c's
that's how i know 80 was a c a z no
80. it was it was like a 193 was an a
92 to 85 was a b wait 92
what kind of school did you go to a
tough one
we had education i don't believe you got
c's i believe you got z's
no and then and then uh it was like 84
84
to like 78 or something was a c
and then 78 to 70 was a
d and then anything below 16 it's like
69 below the f
george's public school system wasn't
like that i took a class a biochemistry
and an organic chemistry class in high
school
everybody dropped out it was me and four
other people left we all got
30s on our final exam and he round what
does that
curve curved it so i ended up getting
like a c or b
in the class because my
this is 34 72 with nerds right this is
the problem with nerds if i was in that
class
i'd have gotten the 30 and he's like you
got an f there's no i've never been in a
class where they were like hey man we
know that this was hard it's like let us
just boost you up a little bit well
that never happened everybody else got
30 so we might as well
yeah i also what were the classes called
organic chemistry and biochemistry
see if i would have seen that on the
paperback by nah switch i got to go do
gym class or film or okay and there were
only like five people in the class and
the saddest part was nobody wanted to be
my partner because i always messed up
the experience i would break something i
would shatter something another another
tip for anybody who's still in school
the nerds all take classes with five
people on it
i never took that i always took the
class with the most kids in it so the
teacher had the lowest possibility of
figuring out that i was the idiot
oh geez no problem all right that's it
for lunch monday today guys
have a great one bang bang while she's
trying to get rich wrestlers trying to
get her lunch money right stay protected
to print lots of money
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fight
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends